here's the news we got for you okay
everyone has been appropriately focused
on these videos that Tucker Carlson's
been releasing from January 6 but Dan
and I got to thinking there was a lot of
paper created during this investigation
the subpoenas the demands for records it
showcases the strategy of how the
January 6 committee would go after a
Target who was working with them who did
they hire to collaborate on this project
it's about two million documents and I
think as far as I know Dan and I are the
first Republican lawmakers to actually
go and spend an extended period of time
going through this information and
here's what we can tell you about it
it's not disorganized
kind of expected on the way out the door
Liz Cheney and Adam kinzinger might have
just opened their binders and thrown
everything into a giant bin shaking it a
few times and said You know here here
are your documents and you know what
this will this will drive you crazy
every Committee in Congress gets to
Define what a committee record is and
what has to be maintained so if they
wanted to the January 6th committee
could have said you know what the
committee records are the public
transcripts of our hearings and
everything else we're destroying and we
would have had no paper trail but
interestingly enough they kept not all
but almost all of the outgoing paperwork
product that they had developed the
letters that they'd sent people the
documents they'd requested the subpoenas
they drafted so all this outgoing the
way that they would Target not just you
but your internet service provider
they'd go to your Telecom company
Verizon they'd go to your bank and we
saw enormous collaboration between some
of these Fortune 100 companies financial
institutions alphabet and the January 6
committee eager to turn over the private
information are these digital files
these were hard paper files that we that
we observed now we're we're like you're
manually turning Pages oh absolutely
yeah further 60 years 80 sort of small
boxes of stuff and some of it's uh
public reports that Matt made mention of
but there's some interesting stuff but
here's What's missing what's missing is
all the paper that was supposed to come
back you see all this out going was
supposed to generate lists of people's
emails texts and we were able to review
some of what came back as a consequence
of those results but there's a huge
dearth there they chose to get rid of
some of those records and some others
were going to chat about it I'd be
interested obviously I have a personal
stake but
how uh they discussed the media
Independent Media that have been talking
about it for me uh it was uh Raskin who
it's funny because he reps the district
right next to where we work out of and
some of our employees are in his
district and he took a clip of me
reading a Fox news headline and played
it alongside someone calling for kicking
in the doors or a red wedding and it's
me being like Donald Trump says there's
going to be a wild night well you know
maybe he's right I mean his supporters
are pretty angry and then he makes it
seem as he says these people were
calling for it I'm curious to see if
behind the scenes they were targeting
independent commentators social media
personalities I assume the answer is yes
they are the masters of the smear oh
yeah they always get their man that way
and you know we'll see what there's some
other there's some interesting Matt sort
of alluded to it there's there are
interesting pointers in the papers that
we saw to finding some other stuff it
could be the mother logo well and
another thing I learned going through
the January 6 committee's work product
is that there is a value at times to a
subpoena even if you aren't seeking
information back as a result of that
subpoena an example is how they what
they dealt with social media companies
imagine being a social media company and
getting subpoena in demand saying show
me everything you're doing to get these
extreme views off of your platform show
me everything you're doing to stop the
next Insurrection show me everything
you're doing to look at the profile of
people who support building the wall and
election integrity and the Second
Amendment and you know let us know that
you're actually being good corporate
citizens you see that's not a subpoena
intended to actually get usable
information back it's coercive in nature
and and they were using those tactics
and the level of detail
and vertically integrated subpoena
strategy was Exquisite let me give you
let me give you an example Tim
they subpoenaed the catering company for
this building that we are in right now
for January 5th and January 6th to see
like if you had people over on January
5th how many cupcakes were delivered
that night and what does that say about
how many people were in a meeting in
your office
so
can you release these documents to the
Press
well we observed them and went through
them today with the permission of the
house administration committee they are
the committee with jurisdiction over the
records of the house and they're working
to get this digitized they have had a
very pro-transparency Outlook but we are
our patience is not one of our virtues
we it's March and we need to start
getting to this information analyzing it
seeing how Americans were targeted Dan
and I are very focused on our work on
the weaponization subcommittee and I
believe the January 6 committee was a
weaponized utilization of the American
government against our people and and
actually it spawned activity from the
Department of Justice that I remain
concerned about to this day I'm gonna
I'm gonna
I I'm just going to come out and say I
think
sometimes you guys maybe because you
have to give a little bit of benefit a
little bit of the benefit of the doubt
to some of your Democrat colleagues
because you have to I'd imagine uh me
I'm under no such constraints and I
think they're evil people maybe maybe
you wouldn't go as far but the idea that
they had access to this footage that
wasn't released that some of these
defendants never got access to it they
tried claiming the defendants did but
they didn't and it shows a very
different picture the fact that Tucker
Carlson in his report when he came out
and showed the video of chancelly calmly
walking through with police trying to
open the door for him
the first thing Tucker Carlson did in
that report was show the violence and
said we've all seen the violence in the
vandalism because we've been shown it
non-stop but here's what you didn't see
what did the the Democrats and the media
do in unison right away instead of
Cherry Picked he cherry-picked and he
lied and he didn't show the violence
because they know their audience will
never actually watch a full Tucker
segment where he does first and foremost
like yes there's violence that's exactly
right I'm sorry I think it's evil
because they've done evil there's no
question about it and if we did that
there would be actions to take our law
licenses away in North Carolina and
Florida if we went out there to Spur
criminal prosecutions and purposefully
withheld material evidence certainly if
we did it in a court of law they
distorted evidence repeatedly during the
course of the January 6 things I mean
you remember Jim Jordan's uh tweet where
they took it he had he had quoted some
something that was quoted they took the
quotes off and made it as if it were Jim
Jordan's statement it was nothing wrong
with the statement particularly anyway
but it gave put words in his mouth that
didn't exist
I was thinking of going to raskin's
office after I saw he did this but you
know I got to tell you
um when when he played that clip of me I
had people I know who are Urban liberal
liberals in Chicago and it was a red
pill moment for them because they were
like my parents were watching this they
saw this clip I saw that and I
immediately was like that's Tim Poole
they're like
like he's like a like a boring fence
sitter guy that's messed up and it
immediately said to them like
something's not right with this picture
yeah so all of a sudden I get these
these liberals that I know being like
I'm not questioning what happened after
I saw that and I actually wrote an op-ed
for Newsweek because Newsweek reached
out to me and they were like we're
familiar with your content this doesn't
seem to make sense so that was a mistake
they smeared too hard and look I isn't
it you get accused of being a left-wing
radical and a right-wing radical on like
a weekly basis isn't that kind of your
thing so in the early days I'm the milk
toast fence sitter that's that's the guy
because I'm like well you know and I
still I put it like this you're an
extreme moderate you're a moderate Rebel
maybe like all those moderate rebels in
Syria we've been given
I'm gonna I'm just gonna I'm just gonna
say it uh reality has a right-wing bias
these days that's the old joke from
Colbert you know reality has a left-wing
bias I guess that's what he said all
those years ago but the the conversation
that we're having right now isn't based
on our views on policy I'm not here
discussing with you pro-life pro-choice
tax policy flat tax progressive tax
we're talking about the facts of January
6. information that was withheld
and that makes you right wing
if the funniest thing about this modern
political landscape is I'm right wing
because I supported the narrative that
conservatives were facing undue
censorship on social media which is so
it's so confirmed now that you're you
you have the the attempt to smear Matt
taibi as a so-called journalist right
who's this like long-standing liberal
award-winning journalist for 30 years
they're calling Matt tabial uh right
winger now you've seen you've seen
people call him a right-wing you know
journalist like I've seen it the
Democrats attacked him with gusts yeah
well I mean that's played it in some
years that was an embarrassment to be
honest with you the the fact that the
Democrats had were trying to get the the
journalists to give up their sources and
trying multiple times over and over and
honestly there's part of me that thinks
that they didn't realize as if they
didn't possess the cognitive octane to
actually understand that they were
trying to get them to give up their
sources they didn't understand the
context and it was painful a couple of
them like
there's multiple layers to this right
the initial layer is you're watching
Democrats attack a long time Rolling
Stone journalist and a guy who's waving
his hand saying I voted for Biden yeah
you know I am not part of Hillary
Clinton's so-called vast right-wing
conspiracy and I think that's easy to
absorb but I think the additional layer
to it is how comprehensive the
censorship industrial complex is that's
what I really want people to take away
from this that this isn't like you know
a few bad actors in one agency this is
enterprise-wide in government the
Department of Homeland Security the
Department of Defense the Department of
Justice even the post office has a
covert program to monitor the political
views of people on social media and so
we got to get our head around that and
rather than patting ourselves on the
back for holding hearings about it we
have to use this process to inform how
we fund the government and one of the
things Dan and I fought really hard for
during the speaker's race was to have
individualized assessments of these
agencies
and it sounds dorky and wonky but I am
tired of voting on some multi-thousand
page bill that spends over a trillion
dollars that funds the government for
the entire year and you don't get to say
okay at a programmatic level here in DOD
FBI how do we excise that out exactly
like vetoes
what's that there should be lying vetoes
like there should be oh line item veto
yeah absolutely I I would
enthusiastically support that under any
a president Republican or Democrat yeah
they're digitizing the January 6 files
all right
is there is there a capability or is
there a security risk like can this be
released to the public maybe maybe the
answer is more like a Twitter file style
approach where some journalists can come
in go through it with you guys and then
redact for security issues things that
might put people in In Harm's Way but
get this information out to the American
people so as to the of God I favor more
disclosure across the board I think
that's the one of our biggest problems
you talked about evil and you talked
about Democrats evil we're talking about
a bigger evil and this is spread across
all these government departments working
together with these with academic pseudo
academics and so forth that Matt was
talking about but yeah I think
um they thrive in secrecy and and that
is a general proposition can these
things all be released there's some
things we saw on there I'm not sure
could a few items but most of it should
be why not let you see you ought to see
what this Committee of Congress decided
they could go do pick a target maybe
I'll take their name off but show the
bank that and the and the the is as Matt
was saying earlier today they they've
picked a Target and then they went and
figured out all their finances they went
and figured out all their means of
communication they've they figured out
all their means of movement it it's it
is otherworldly and you can't believe
that kind of thing goes on the United
States the way to stop it is for people
to know that it happens and I I should
clarify too I suppose
there were there were Republicans on
that on that panel I mean not the
Republicans anyone actually wanted to be
nana yeah but you had kinzinger and
Cheney who you know exactly in name and
as far as anyone was concerned they were
effectively Democrats but that really
says a lot one thing I noticed was that
the Republicans had extraordinary
influence over the committee
um we got into some of the January 6
committee's staff files and one thing I
took a particular note of is that Adam
kinzinger was able to place a
hand-picked CIA lawyer into the general
counsel's office of the House of
Representatives to Gaslight or like all
these subpoenas to torch Americans to
smear them and and they were assembling
people not from the traditional group
that you would think for Congressional
staff but they were finding sharp tooth
lawyers in the Department of Justice the
FBI the CIA
high-end State Attorney's offices
they were finding people all over the
country they were bringing high-end
left-wing talent in to operationalize
that Force thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at 8
pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time